all right thank you ted we're breaking
now out of north las vegas police are
investigating a homicide right now they
tell us a man was shot and killed near
cheyenne avenue and commerce street orca
mana joins us live now from the scene
with what officers are saying about the
suspect orco
well christian north las vegas police
say that they found the victim dead
inside a car here just before noon you
can see that north las vegas police is
still on scene with detectives and the
csi team trying to piece together what
happened north las vegas police say they
got a report of someone shot inside a
car here at englestad and burning sun
when police got here they found a man in
his 20's dead from an apparent gunshot
wound police are now looking for a
suspect vehicle they say it's a faded
black
2003-2005 ford f-150 with the black
folded cover and a raiders logo on the
passenger door police say they need your
help finding it
we want to make sure that even though
suspicious activity is not illegal if
you see something please say something
because it can save lives
now if you know anything about what
happened here or if you have seen that
suspect vehicle you're asked to call
north las vegas police or crime stoppers
where you can remain anonymous reporting
live in north las vegas orca mana 8 news
now